Musik, Musik, Musik, Gesang,, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, kastram, am, fah, um, ab, ab, ab, spars, ab, has, ich, es, bar, ab
Wir heben ab, ab, ab, kastram, am, fah, um, ab, spars, ab, has, ich, es, bar, ab
Wir heben ab, ab, ab, kastram, am, fah,, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab, ab mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mir, mit mirteres Potpourri, ein Gemisch aus verschiedenen Farben. Es kann im Grunde alles passieren. Es kann alles passieren heute, wir wissen nicht, wer noch durch diese Tür kommt. Hey, ich bin's, Stefan. Bevor es gleich losgebe mit der Folge, wie letztes Jahr auch schon, der Aufruf an euch, an die Podcast-Sufu-Community, denn wir drehen wieder How to Sell Drugs Online Fest, wir drehen Staffel zwei für Netflix und wir suchen Komparsen. Und zwar am 7.11.2019 suchen wir eine Menge Komparsen, egal ob ihr männlich seid oder weiblich. Hauptsache ihr seid irgendwo im Alter, irgendwo so roundabout 18 bis 23 und habt Bock an unserer Schule Schüler zu spielen. Aber wir suchen auch Erwachsene, denn es gibt ja natürlich auch Lehrer, so keine Ahnung, 35 bis 60 Jahre wären da interessant. Und die könnten den ganzen Tag bei uns am Set verbringen. Es gibt Frühstück, es gibt Mittagessen und ihr könnt bei uns mit dem Team abhängen. Wenn ihr darauf Bock habt, dann schreibt eine Mail an htsdof at btf.de, htsdof at btf.de und schreibt am besten Name, Vorname, Handynummer, Konfektionsgröße und Schuhgröße mit dazu und am besten noch ein schönes Foto von euch, wo man euch auch erkennt. Oder auch ein nicht so schönes Foto, Hauptsache man erkennt euch sehr gut. Das Ganze findet in Bonn statt und ja, ich hoffe, dass viele von euch Bock drauf haben. Letztes Mal hat das auch mega funktioniert, vielen Dank nochmal. Ich denke, ich werde auch wieder vorbeischauen und dann ja, vielleicht sehe ich ja ein paar von euch. Findest du nicht, manche Räume sind einfach viel zu fucking hoch? Ich mag hohe Räume sehr. Ja? Ich finde, ja, als grosser Mensch vielleicht auch deswegen, ich komme mir oft, komme ich mir zu klein vor, zu gross vor in vielen Räumen, dieser Raum gibt mir das Gefühl, dass es noch viel zu entdecken gibt in der Welt. Es gibt noch viel zu streben. Es ist ein bisschen, ich habe mir so ein bisschen das Gefühl, vielleicht hat sich der Architekt verkalkuliert. Ich glaube, dass sich Architekten regelmäßig so hoch sind vier Meter. Ich denke mir aber auch immer, weil drei Meter klingt nicht groß, ehrlich gesagt. Drei Meter klingt nicht hoch. Und dann steht man auf einem Drei-Meter-Brett im Schwimmbad und denkt sich, holy shit sind drei Meter hoch. Drei Meter sind riesig hoch. Auf einem Drei-Meter-Brett kann ich den Unterschied zwischen drei Metern und einem Kilometer nicht unterscheiden. Weißt du, was auch hoch ist? Vier Meter. Alter, vier Meter sind auch richtig hoch. Ich glaube, es fleischte ich nicht so sehr, weil bei vier Metern klingt es schon hoch. Und dann stehst du auf dem Vier-Meter-Brett und denkst, ja, ist hoch. Bei drei Metern denkst du, ich bin fast drei Meter groß. Was dann aber wieder sehr hoch ist, ist der Fünf-Meter-Türm. Der ist wieder riesig. Ein halbes Dutzend ist fast ein halbes Dutzend. Ja, aber bei fünf denkt man nicht, bei fünf denkt man ja fast, also die Hälfte von zehn Metern. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber dann ist man da oben und denkt, oh, selbst das ist schon groß. Liest du manchmal noch Märchen? Ist das ein Thema, das sich für dich noch ergibt? Gar kein Thema. Gar kein Thema? Null. Überhaupt nicht. Nee, ich habe aktiv auch, glaube ich, erwoidet in meinem Leben. Märchen. Finde ich ganz furchtbar. Die machen mir auch Angst. Ich grusel mich vor Märchen. Aber ist Märchen eine Kunstform, die ausgestorben ist, oder gibt es noch moderne Märchen? Also irgendwie so. Würdest du nicht sagen, dass Star Wars die Rückkehr der Jedi. Ich fände mir aber weiter, mach weiter. Die Rückkehr der was? Red weiter, red weiter. Red ruhig weiter. Red weiter, gehen ein bisschen tiefer rein noch.
Ja, ich bin dabei.
Gehen ein bisschen tiefer rein noch, das war mir nicht tief genug.
Dass der Trailer, der heute rausgekommen ist, der Trailer zu einem Film war.
Noch eine Ebene tiefer.
Wie soll ich tiefer gehen, wenn du die ganze Zeit durch Triebe auskommst?
Die Helden macht die Helden rein.
Ein bisschen tiefer.
Dass der nicht, dass es nicht ein Märchen ist?
Ist da auch nicht ein Märchen?
Das ist mir nicht tief genug.
Machen wir Politik, machen wir Politik jetzt. Machen wir Politik, machen wir Politik jetzt.
Machen wir Politik, machen wir was raus, Politik.
Machen wir was raus.
Findest du nicht, dass Donald Trump ein modernes Märchen ist?
Ja, Sport, jetzt Sport.
Findest du nicht, dass der FC Bayern München ein modernes Märchen ist?
Religion?
Dass die Geschichte von zwei Päpsten, die es ja gibt.
Und wieder zurück zu Sport?
Die es im Fussball ja auch gibt durch Leute wie ... Kleinen Abstecher zur Politik noch? Politik ist ja auch Sport. Und zurück zu Star Wars. Wie man im neuen Star Wars Trailer begut. Du kannst alles, du kannst alle Themen, du kannst alle Themen. Ich bin im Grunde überall zu Hause. Da hat mich mein Journalismusstudium auch gut vorbereitet. Wie geht's dir? Ihr, ihr, ihr, ihr, ihr, ihr. Wir sind gerade in diesem helligen Raum. Ich weiß nicht, ob es unbedingt auch in der Deckenhöhe, ich habe Hall auch nicht hundertprozentig verstanden, weil, also ist es nicht so, im Tonstudio gibt es keine 90-Grad-Winkel. Richtig, weil 90-Grad-Winkel verursacht hat, ist das korrekt? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Das einzige, was ich nur letztens gesehen habe, was mich fasziniert hat, war zum Thema, wie Noise-Canceling Sachen funktionieren. Und zwar wurde dann so ein ganz einfaches Experiment gemacht, und zwar wurde jemand hingesetzt an den Tisch und dem gegenüber zwei Boxen, aus denen dasselbe Tonsignal kommt. Sagen wir jetzt mal Hey Chihuahua von DJ Bobo. So, beides das gleiche Tonsignal. Sagen wir einfach mal. Ja, aus beiden Boxen kommt das gleiche Tonsignal. Das ist nicht das, was nach Sagen wir einfach mal normalerweise kommt. Obwohl, es ist falsch, es stimmt, es ist falsch, du hast recht. Ne, sagen wir mal, da kommt jetzt ein Ton raus, sagen wir mal Cis. Ja, das ist was, was nach Sagen wir mal kommt. Cis. Ja. Die ganze Zeit. Nichts anderes, nur aus beiden Boxen gleichzeitig. Und jetzt, wenn man die jetzt verschiebt so ein bisschen, also eine Box ein bisschen näher an den Betrachterrand zieht, dann ab einem gewissen Punkt hört man nichts mehr. Weil die Schallwellen sich genau auscanceln. Sinus und Cosinus. Ja, die canceln sich aus. Das ist null. Wie verrückt ist das denn, dass du zwei Boxen hast und wenn du einen Stück weiter nach vorne schiebst, hörst du nichts mehr. Und wenn du dann aber wieder einen Schritt zur Seite gehst, hörst du wieder was. Und dann wird es wieder lauter. Es ist total verrückt, aber es ist halt einfach so. Ja, Schall ist, glaube ich, auch noch, da muss noch eine Menge passieren. In der Forschung, glaube ich, ist man das so nicht verstanden.
Kann man Schall nicht mal sichtbar machen? Bei mir ist auch immer noch die Frage, wie funktionieren Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer? In Gottes Namen, wie funktionieren sie? Weil Echtzeit, das ist das Wort, was mich am meisten fasziniert in Bezug auf Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer. Weil die hören ja genauso schnell wie mein Ohr und noch schneller. Aber die müssen ja eigentlich, pass auf, die übersetzen ja das Geräusch, was es gibt in der Umgebung, simultan leiser machen die das. Die pegeln das runter, was im Hintergrund ist. Das heißt, die müssen ja erahnen, dass gleich das Baby schreit, was es runterpegelt. Die haben genau den Abstand zwischen den beiden Boxen Zeit. Weil dadurch, dass sie genau versetzt ihr Signal senden, haben die genau die Zeit der Zwischenzeit. Und wenn die hören, oh Baby, sagen die jetzt Baby und dadurch ist es gleichzeitig versetzt und wieder weg. Antibaby. Antibaby, direkt Antibaby. Aber es gibt ja auch tatsächlich, was ja auch momentan groß im Kommen ist, ist Cloud Gaming, dass man die Spiele nicht mehr auf seinem eigenen Apparillo hat.
Das sagt mir gerade nichts, Flonti, da muss man mich nochmal ein...
Normalerweise, wenn du daddelst, dann hast du das Game
ja auf deinem eigenen Apparillo, ja, dann hast du ja
irgendwie, hast du die Maschine da.
Da kann ich connecten, weil
Leuten die Apparillo sagen, bin ich sofort
in einem Boot. Und der
Trend ist aber, dass der Apparillo
weit, weit weg ist. Beim Teflon.
Beim Teflon. Stell dir vor, statt dass du selber Pokémon spielst ... Beim Teflon neben dem Schlepptop. Genau. Jemand anders hat einen Schlepptop. Ein Dieb klaut deinen Schlepptop von zu Hause. Räuber. Ja, zum Bleistift. Ein Dieb klaut ihn. Und jetzt anstatt dass du selber spielst, brüllst du dem Dieb zu, links, links, links, und der Dieb spielt für dich und sagt, 100 Punkte, verstehst du, du spielst nicht direkt, sondern du rufst es jemandem zu, der für dich spielt und dir die Ergebnisse wieder zurückspiegelt. Genauso funktioniert Cloud Gaming oder, ich weiß nicht, ist vielleicht der falsche Begriff, aber vielleicht war es auch Zitronensäurezyklus, irgend so was in der Richtung. Auf jeden Fall, dass du übers Internet deine Signale irgendwo hinschickst und da wird für dich gespielt und du kriegst nur noch das Bild zurück. Das heißt, das Spiel findet gar nicht auf deinem eigenen Rechner statt. Clever. So. Und was die jetzt vorgestellt haben, ist, dass sie durch KI wollen die deinen nächsten Zug, deine nächste Eingabe vorhersagen. Das heißt, wir kommen an den Punkt, wo man gar nicht mehr selber spielen muss, wo du einfach im Bett liegst und Leute den Spaß haben, den du gehabt hättest, hältst du dich aufgerafft, um jetzt in den nächsten fünf Minuten am Politik zu sein. Ja, weil irgendwann musst du das Spiel ja gar nicht mehr, das Bild gar nicht mehr zurückbekommen, sondern der Computer bekommt das Bild wieder selber. Ich finde gut, in zwei Jahren zwei Freunde, können wir immer eine Black-Mirror-Episode schreiben,, zwei Freunde verabreden sich zum FIFA zocken und ein Controller werden eingestöpselt, einer ist leer natürlich, muss aufgeladen werden, möchte noch ein Bier, ja, der erste steht auf, setzen sich hin, machen den Fernseher an und da steht das Ergebnis, was am Ende rausgekommen wäre, hätten sie ineinander gespielt. Okay, Black Mirror Intro, Exterior Sportplatz, Paul, ein viriler Mitsechziger mit Kekkerfrisur und einer Brille auf dem Kopf, also auf den Augen, tritt mit voller Wucht den Ball, verfehlt leider und pfeffert das Ding ordentlich ein gutes Stück hin das Tor. Daneben sein bester Freund Mirko. Paul? Hi Mirko. Mirko. Hi Paul, wollen wir nicht darüber reden, dass du den Ball gerade ordentlich über die Stange gepfeffert hast? Nein, ich wollte erst mal Hallo sagen, Hi. Oh, da habe ich aber den Ball gerade ordentlich in die Maschen gehauen. Ne, eben nicht, du hast ihn eben nicht in die Maschen gehauen. Was sagt man, mir fehlen jetzt auch die Sportbüche. Meinst du, die Tatsache, dass wir keinen klaren Gedanken mehr fassen können, hängt mit unserer digitalisierten Welt zusammen? Ja, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Weil wir ja nur noch auf unsere Bling-Bling-Gadgets achten und gar nicht mehr miteinander wirklich reden können.
Ja, genau daran wird es liegen, Paul. Oder was, Beiko?
Siehst du, ich glaube, diese ganzen Daten steigen mir in meinem Hirn.
Oder dass man durch Social Media gar nicht mehr weiß, wer man wirklich ist, dass du gefangen bist, zwischen dem Bild ist und dem Haus.
Der Black Mirror ist auch nicht mehr das, was es mal war, muss man wirklich mal sagen. Stimmt, die hätten nicht einfach sieben Staffeln bestellt. Oh mein Gott, es ist wirklich das grauenhaft geworden. Ja, es ist wirklich schlecht geworden. Naja, wer ist gut, für das zu entscheiden? Finde ich, das ist auch gut geworden. Die nennen das negative Latenz. Also nicht, dass das Spiel hinterherhängt, sondern dass das Spiel dir einen Schritt voraus ist. Und der wird wahrscheinlich eh gleich A drücken, also gehen wir mal von A aus. Wahnsinn. Wahnsinn.
Gibt es einen Spieler auf der Welt, der die A-Taste angemessen oft benutzt?
Oder sagen wir mal, ich denke eher an Controller beim Playstation oder bei der Xbox.
Aber diese X-Taste, die rückt man doch überproportional häufig.
Aber warum ausgerechnet da, warum macht der Mensch das nicht immer? Du klingelst halt einmal an der Tür.
Aber diese X-Taste wird einfach, die wird gemolken.
Ein Wort für dich, Kugelschreiber.
Ja, der Kugelschreiber wird auch gemolken.
Vielleicht zwei Wörter.
Vielleicht drei Wörter. Das ist ein zusammengees Wort. Ja, Rechtschreib, ja. Ja, du benutzt zu häufig den Kugelschreiber, Auslöser. Weißt du, was ich manchmal mache? Ich nehme den Kugelschreiber an der langen Seite und toppe dann so auf den Tisch mit dem Klicker. Ja, das ist der befriedigste Geräusche der Welt. Das ist super Spaß, das ist Das ist grossartig. Es gab doch diesen Fidget-Hype, der ist vorüber. Man hat genug gefidget. Ja, eigentlich dachte man eigentlich, okay, jetzt hat man das Kern des Menschenbedürfnis endlich entschlüsselt und weiß, der Mensch will einfach nur an Dingern rumfingern den ganzen Tag. Und warum hat sich das nicht durchgesetzt? Elektroroller. Ja, ist der nächste Hype. Hat es ab. Hat es abgelöst, ja. Apropos Elektroroller, du fragst dich wahrscheinlich, wo kommt das ganze Strom her? Ja, das frage ich mich. Wie können so wenige Menschen so viel Strom erzeugen? Ja, deswegen bin ich hier in der Sendung. Ja. Weil ich diese Frage habe und sie, wie will das Konzept? Das hat ein bisschen lange gedauert, bis wir zu dem Punkt kommen, aber ja, deswegen dachte ich mir, okay, ich will ein bisschen Strom für die anderen übrig lassen, weil ich verwende vielleicht zu viel Strom oder mit den anderen ihren E-Rollern. Du bist echt in der Stromphase. Ich bin in der Stromphase. Ich will diesen Story-Arc jetzt aber auch beenden. Mit dem Kühlschrank. Mit dem Kühlschrank, ja. Ich messe den Strom meines Kühlschranks, um rauszufinden. Wird er jetzt just in diesem Moment gemessen? Justamente, in diesem Moment wird auch der Strom gemessen. Und Stefan Tietze, ja, hat ja direkt, ist mir direkt in die Parade gefahren und meinte, na, mach das mal nicht, das ist eh sinnlos, ich weiß es eh besser. Ja, das war nicht mein Wortlaut. Ich habe aber gesagt, ich habe gesagt, du vollidiot, du verbrauchst wahrscheinlich mehr Strom beim Testen, als würdest du einfach ausmachen. Richtig, ich habe aber gesagt, ich bin ein experimenteller Wissenschaftler, ich will das rausfinden. So, und die Fragestellung war präzise, wie lange muss man den Kühlschrank ausmachen, damit man insgesamt Strom spart. Ja, top. Die Daten sind da. Die Daten sind da. Wie aufwendig war es? Es war nicht sehr aufwendig. Ich habe ein Messgerät gefunden, das sich mit meinem Router verbindet. Genial, weil dadurch sammelt mein Router die Daten und ich kann wegwerfen. Ich bin jetzt schon enttäuscht, weil ich dachte, du baust, du bastelst was. Nee, ich dachte, du hast so einen Raspberry Pi Computer, lötest ein bisschen rum und baust dir dazu irgendwie so eine WiFi-Antenne, die sich mit deinem Router verbindet, was du aber selber programmieren musst. Alles nicht getan, du hast diese einfache Lösung. Du hast ja, obwohl du dich das machst, um dich zu beschäftigen, deiner Langeweile zu frönen, also trotzdem die Abkürzung genommen, um dann wieder Langeweile zu haben. Das ist der menschliche Paradox, an was ich nicht verstehen werde. Ich habe zu viel Geld ausgegeben, um Zeit zu sparen, die ich eigentlich damit verbrauchen möchte. Auch um Geld zu sparen. Ich habe zu viel Zeit und zu wenig Geld und jetzt habe ich es noch schlimmer gemacht dadurch.
Und ich gebe dir einfach mal die Daten und du hast jetzt die Aufgabe, diese Daten für unsere Zuschauer anschaulich zu machen.
Ja, wie ein klassischer Wissenschaftsjournalist.
Klassischer, sehr gut. Und zwar sind das mal die Daten für den heutigen Tag.
So, ich zeige dir mal die Daten für den heutigen Tag. Wenn es ist, wie bei unseren Hörerstatistiken auf unserer Website, weiß ich nicht genau, was es, oh Gott. Das sind die Daten für den heutigen Tag. Jetzt mach mal für den geneigten Zuschauer die Daten anschaulich, was siehst du? Also ich sehe sehr viele Balken, was mich jetzt mal verwirrt ein bisschen, weil ich habe ehrlich gesagt einen Graphen, einen verbundenen linearen Verlauf. Also Enttäuschung, du kannst auch deine emotionale Reise. Massive Enttäuschung, Wut und Irritation. Ungeduld vielleicht ein bisschen? Nein. Wir haben sehr viele Balken, bestehend aus vier kleinen Balken. Jetzt steht da oben, was ist W, H, Watt, Kilowattstunde wahrscheinlich, Wattstunde. Das ist nicht Kilowattstunde, weil dann wieder ein K da vorne. Wattstunde, der Stromverbrauch also. Frustration, höre ich da ein bisschen Frustration aus? Mittlerweile ist einfach nur in Wut umgeschlagen. Alles klar. Also Y-Achse ist Kilowattstunde, X-Achse ist Uhrzeit. So. Jetzt versuch uns doch mal den Kern dieser Messdaten. Genau, also wir haben unten die Uhrzeit. Jetzt sehen wir zum Beispiel mal, wir fangen mal an bei sechs Uhr. Sechs Uhr in der Früh sind wir bei einem Verbrauch von 12,5 Kilowattstunden. Aber auch nur ganz kurz, weil dann so gegen halb sieben kein Verbrauch mehr herrscht.
Ich hätte den Kühlschrank jetzt kaputt, um nicht zu sein.
Du hast gar keinen Verbrauch mehr herrscht. Ich hätte den Kühlschrank jetzt kaputt, um ehrlich zu sein. Du hast gar keinen Verbrauch mehr, keinen Schluftverbrauch. Gegen sieben Uhr ist komplett gar kein Verbrauch mehr. Dann so gegen Viertel nach sieben sind wir wieder bei ungefähr 12,5 im Schnitt Kilowattstunden Verbrauch. Das zieht sich dann so durch bis ungefähr acht, dann nimmt es wieder massiv ab. Okay, also es gibt Phasen. Du hast wie so die Sinuskurve mässig. Genau. Und du hast so, sagen wir mal, ungefähr zu jeder vollen Stunde bis in grössere Intervalle hast du einen Verbrauch von 12,5 Kilowattstunden. Genau, alle Stunde hört der für 15 Minuten auf zu arbeiten, hat keinen Verbrauch mehr. Das ist doch bescheuert. Das heisst, der kühlt sich, der macht genau das, was du messen wolltest, ob das überhaupt Sinn macht für mehrere Tage, macht der zwölfmal am Tag. Das heißt, der macht alle 15 Minuten, also alle Stunden hat er 15 Minuten, macht er nichts mehr. Das heißt, der kühlt sich immer auf in der Temperatur und hört dann auf. So, das heißt, was ist das jetzt erstmal schon mal für ein Messergebnis für dich? Was kannst du daraus ziehen? Also, dass der schubweise kühlt, bis er wieder runterkühlt, bis er sich wieder aufwärmt, der Kühlschrank, und dann, ich nehme an, da ist ein Thermometer drin. So, und der misst, was im Kühlschrank vor sich geht. Und sobald die Temperatur einen kritischen Messwert erreicht, nämlich zu warm, geht er an und kühlt wieder runter. Das heißt, da hast du so peakweise, hast du dann immer eine Stunde Dampf und dann wieder nicht. So, bevor wir jetzt weitermachen, brauche ich erstmal deine Schätzung. Was glaubst du, was ist die Antwort auf die Frage, wie viele Tage muss man den Kühlschrank ausmachen, damit er insgesamt Strom spart? Um ehrlich zu sein, nach diesem Graphen würde ich sagen, 15 Minuten. Mhm, okay, du sagst 15 Minuten. Etwas anders als deine vorherige Schätzung, wo du gesagt hast, nee, drei Tage reichen nicht. Wir gehen mal weiter. Nächste Statistik sagt jetzt wöchentlich. So, in dem Zeitraum war der Kühlschrank aus. Du siehst die ganze Zeit, hier ist kein Verbrauch. Ja, Dead Space. Also jetzt haben wir hier nur noch, jetzt sind wir bei Kilowattstunden, vorher waren wir bei Wattstunden, jetzt sind wir bei 0,15 Kilowattstunden, die du von Mittwoch, den Mittwoch und Donnerstag hattest. Im Schnitt ist es relativ gleichbleibend, dann hast du den Kühlschrank ausgemacht und dann geht es wieder los und dann natürlich, wenn du den Kühlschrank anmachst, ist der Verbrauch schnell in die Höhe.
Aber was würdest du sagen im Verhältnis zu dem normalen Verbrauch? Wie hoch ist der Verbrauch, wenn er von null auf kühlen muss?
Ja, von 0,15 Kilowattstunden auf 0,25 Kilowattstunde. Das ist schon ordentlich. Also 50 Prozent deutlich mehr.
Also er muss für ungefähr eine Viertelstunde 50 Prozent mehr kühlen und danach ist es wieder normal. Danach ist es wieder cool. Also eine Viertelstunde lang 50 Prozent mehr. Also er muss für ungefähr eine Viertelstunde 50 Prozent mehr kühlen und danach ist wieder normal. Danach ist wieder cool. Also eine Viertelstunde lang 50 Prozent mehr. Wahnsinn. Ich glaube aber, der Kühlschrank, ist der alt schon? Ne, na ja, doch. Doch, ich glaube schon. Also das heißt, das Ergebnis meiner Messung lautet, es reicht schon, den Kühlschrank 15 Minuten lang auszumachen und man spart schon Strom. Quod errat wie die Wizi. Das Ding ist, ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert. So, und jetzt möchte ich, dass du dich entschuldigst bei mir, dass du mich für so dumm gehalten hast, dass ich mein ganzes Leben lang bis jetzt Strom verbraucht habe. Ich spar, und das Faszinierende ist, dass man sich bei dieser Statistik, kann man sich auch den Euroverbrauch anzeigen lassen.
Was meinst du denn, was kostet es denn, ungefähr einen Kühlschrank einen Monat lang zu betreiben?
Was kostet es, einen Kühlschrank einen Monat lang zu betreiben?
Ja, schatz mal, schatz mal.
Du hast doch selber die Antwort auch nicht darauf.
Du bist so weltfremd, du fliegst über den Ding.
Nur weil du denkst, dass du hier irgendwie in Märchen, in solchen Dimensionen arbeitest, musst du dich mit dem normalen Verbrauch nicht beschäftigen.
Ich verstehe es sehr, aber auch du hinaus willst. Also ich weiß nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung von Stromkosten. Wo hast du denn die Antwort überhaupt?
Ich habe die Antwort, ja.
Wie teuer es ist, einen Kühlschrank einen Monat lang zu betreiben?
15 Euro.
60 Cent.
Für mich allerdings 45 Cent. Weil du den ausmachst. Weil ich den ausmache. Und somit richtig saftig Strom sparen. Das sind die Dimensionen, über die wir hier sprechen. Ich habe das echt deutlich zu hoch gegriffen, das ist mir auch gerade aufgefallen. Weil ich stelle mir vor, alle Dinge wären so teuer. Also, wie wenig Gedanken man sich über die Welt macht? Ich habe auch mal ausgerechnet, wie lange es dauert, bis ich die Kosten von dem Messgerät wieder drin habe, dadurch, dass ich spare. Und es waren über 20 Jahre. Ja. Also ich muss jetzt noch eine ganze Weile das betreiben. Aber ich glaube, du hast die Welt ein bisschen zu einem besseren Ort gemacht auf eine Art. Wobei, wenn es eine Viertelstunde dauert, den Kühlschrank auf Temperatur zu bringen. Aber der Tipp an euch da draußen, wenn ihr mal einen langen Spaziergang macht, macht den Kühlschrank aus. Ja, immer unter der Prämisse, dass ihr nichts im Kühlschrank habt. Ja, das ist natürlich ein guter Punkt. Und man müsste den Test natürlich nochmal machen mit einem vollgepackten Kühlschrank. Ja, weil wie gesagt, jemand, der diesen Test durchführt, hat offenbar so einen leeren Kühlschrank, dass ich gar nicht verstehe, warum ein Kühlschrank überhaupt ins Mobilar deine Ausstattung gehört. Das brauchst du ja nicht, du brauchst ja keinen Kühlschrank. Dann sag, ciao, goodbye Kühlschrank und kümmere dich lieber um Dinge, die man Warnersen lagern kann, die Konserven, die sie halten. Das ist natürlich auch ein Punkt. Du kannst dich langfristig von diesen 60 Cent im Monat verabschieden. Meinst du? Ja. Du, dann würde es mehrere Milliarden Jahre dauern, bis ich davon tatsächlich irgendwas spüren würde bei meinem täglichen Umsatz. Ich gebe extrem wenig Geld aus. Ich weiß, ich gebe sehr viel Geld aus. Wir sind da diametral gegenüber den Städten. Soll ich dir Geld geben? Nee, das will ich auch nicht. Ich habe jetzt aber gemerkt, um noch zum Thema Black Mirror zurückzukommen, der moderne Mensch ist ein Stein in einer Dominokette.
Und es kann ganz schnell gehen, dass da der Bär seine Haare hat.
Das kleine Clown Haare hat.
Ja.
Dass der Clown aufhört zu lachen.
Es ist wirklich, mein Konto war kurzzeitig nicht gedeckt.
Meinst du euch auch, ja. Und es ist alles zusammengebrochen, alles. Miete konnte nicht abgebucht werden, Spotify konnte nicht abgebucht werden, Dropbox, alles konnte nicht abgebucht werden. Sämtliche Dienste haben sich automatisch gelöscht, Car2Go, alles Account gesperrt, sämtliche Accounts wurden gesperrt, alle haben in der einzelnen Mail geschrieben, Hier, hier, hier, muss sich immer noch händisch überall Sachen überweisen.
Man merkt wirklich als moderner, digitaler Mensch, es kann ganz schnell gehen und alles bricht zusammen. Du bist letztlich nur so gut wie deine Internetverbindung dann auch. Ja. Ja. Und es ist auch so wirklich, man denkt sich, oh, es ist ja alles nett, es ist ja alles cool, alles super bequem. Sobald du einen Moment Schwäche zeigst, ist alles weg. Das sind nicht deine Freunde, diese Dienste, die du benutzt, das sind Gegner. Doch, die sind deine Freunde, solange dein Konto gedeckt ist. Aber in dem Moment, in der Sekunde, wenn die dein Konto leergesaugt haben, kommt die Giftschlange rausgestochen und beißt dir in den Nacken. Oder Giftschlange. Ja, ich hätte neulich mein Display kaputt von meinem Handy, und dann musste ich das abgeben, und es wurde repariert einen Tag lang. Und ich wusste nicht, wie ich von dem Ort, wo ich mein Handy abgegeben habe, wegkommen sollte. Weil dann ist mir klar geworden, alles läuft auf meinem Handy. Car to go, Roller, mein U-Bahn-Ticket ist auch auf meinem Handy. Du setzt dich einfach so vor die Tür und wartest einfach so eine Woche. Was soll ich tun? Und ich kann auch nicht bezahlen mehr, weil Paypal ist auch auf meinem Konto.
Also alles, dann ist man wirklich, man merkt erst mal, wie abhängig man ist, wenn es dann mal fehlt.
Und vor allem Handy abgeben für den Tag war ja vor wenigen Jahren noch gar kein Thema, würde man niemals darüber sprechen.
Und als du dein Handy wieder abholen wolltest, konntest du nicht bezahlen, weil du kein Paypal hattest und du hast dein Handy bei und du bist verloren. Geben sie nur mein Handy, dann kann ich sie ja bezahlen. Nein, sie kriegen ihr Handy erst, wenn sie bezahlen können. Und dann hast du dich in die Kamera gesetzt und hast gesagt, moderne Gesellschaft. So nicht. Ein Buch von Stefan, äh Film, ich komme noch mal rein. Moderne Märchen von Erik Emanuel Tietze. Tietze. Ja, das ist ein großes Problem tatsächlich, aber da hast du recht. Und jetzt mittlerweile alles wieder im Griff oder ich schreibe immer noch Firmen? Ne, es geht, aber es ist Tröpfel zu rein, so hier und da, man merkt es immer und ich habe, deswegen dachte ich, okay, ich steige. Eigentlich aber gut, weil du merkst, dann tröpfeln auch Dinge rein, wo du merkst, Moment mal, euch gebe ich jeden Monat Geld, habt ihr nicht verdient. Ja, das stimmt. Wer seid ihr, iCloud-Speicherplatz, wofür brauche ich das? Ich habe mich mittlerweile so in der Sackgasse manövriert, dass ich bei manchen Diensten mehrere Abonnements habe.
Beim selben Dienst mehrere Accounts mit mehreren Abonnements. Aber dass Sie auch nicht die Humanität besitzen, zu sagen, sorry, die zahlen Doppelbaut.
Ja, stimmt schon.
Ich bin auch der größte Vollidiot.
Und ich habe den Fehler gemacht, ich habe jemandem einen Dienst geschenkt.
So, hey, ich schenke dir einen Monat Netflix. Ja, kam raus, ich schenke dir drei Jahre Netflix. Ich schenke dir den Rest unseres Lebens Netflix und darüber hinaus, weil wenn ich sterbe, ich werde nicht kurz bevor ich sterbe noch meinen Netflix-Account löschen, hundertprozentig nicht. Und deswegen war es das. Mein gesamtes Erbe wird aufgefressen werden von diesen Diensten. Es ist alles weg. Es ist alles weg. Es ist alles weg. Ja, ich hänge auch in so vielen Abos drin und so. Eigentlich muss man das mal machen. Einmal im Monat sein Handy abgeben und einmal im Monat sein Konto nicht decken. Bewusst das Geld umlagern, um zu gucken, wer meldet sich jetzt. Mal gucken. Welche Verwandten schreiben plötzlich, hey Stefan, wie geht es dir denn? du? Netflix, ähm, klappt ja nicht mehr. Genau, hast du eigentlich schon diese neue Netflix-Serie gesehen, weil ich nicht. Weil, ähm, du, war ja immer so. Ist das denn eigentlich, hast du nervige Verwandte, die an deinem Rockzipfel hängen? Das Problem ist, dass viele Verwandte diesen Podcast hören, deswegen kann ich da jetzt nichts zu sagen. Ich habe hier viele nervige Freunde, die auch viele Podcast hören. Und einer, der auch diesen Podcast hört, benutzt auch meinen Netflix-Account. Und ich weiß, dass er, also Netflix erhöht er ab und zu die Preise. Und ich schicke dann immer so, ich melde mich nicht so häufig bei dir, das weiß ich auch, sorry. Aber immer so, wenn der, ich melde mich immer, wenn er sich eingeloggt hat in den Netflix-Account, weil ich sehe immer, wenn er sich einloggt in einem neuen Netflix-Account und ich frage dann immer so, neue Playstation, weil ich kriege immer eine Mail, es wurde sich neu angemeldet auf der Playstation. Sein Lamborghini angemeldet, ah, okay, hast du ein neues Auto, hast du ein Geld bekommen? Gut, mit Fernsehenden im Auto, wow. Dann kannst du dir offensichtlich auch den Monatsbeitrag leisten. Und er zahlt nicht den angemessenen Preis, zumal Netflix immer die Preise erhöht. Und ich mich immer nur zu Preiserhöhungen melde, immer so, hey, wie ist denn? Du, 1,50 Euro mehr. Und dann kommt immer so ein, ja, ja, ich stelle jetzt um,
bis heute nicht geschehen, dreimal,
bis heute gesagt, dreimal ist nicht geschehen,
also, ich
komme nochmal auf dich zurück, wenn du dich
das nächste Mal irgendwo anmeldest,
bei der nächsten Xbox oder sowas,
sieht man nämlich alles. Ich finde das auch ein nettes Podcast-Konzept,
einfach ein Podcast nur für seine
Freundinnen und Verwandten veröffentlichen, wo man
völlig anonym die Leute anspricht, die aber schon wissen, wer gemeint ist und man so unangenehmen Konfrontationen aus dem Weg geht. Ja, gibt es das nicht? Charlotte Roche und ihr Mann machen zumindest so etwas Ähnliches. Ach, dass sie nicht telefonieren, sondern sich gegenseitig Podcasts schicken oder wie? Nee, die nehmen halt zusammen den Podcast auf, in dem sie sich Dinge sagen, die für die Öffentlichkeit vielleicht nicht bestimmt sind. Ach so. Ich habe drei Netflix-Accounts, also ich habe drei Benutzer auf meinem Netflix-Account. Ich habe einmal, klar, klassisch, Florentin. Dann Florentin traurig. Dann Florentin guckt traurige Dinge. Zweiter Benutzer Will. Interessant. Dritter Benutzer Florentin Will. Ah, okay. Also es ist für jeden was dabei und jeder kann da mal rein, Sepp. Ich habe nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung, was Will und Florentin Will. Ah, okay. Es ist für jeden was dabei.
Und jeder kann da mal rein-zappen.
Ich habe nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung, was Will und Florentin Will so treiben.
Aber es ist... Was? Aber bist du Herr über diese drei...
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Hast du mal auf Will geklickt und geguckt, was der so guckt?
Nee, traue ich mich nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil die haben auch Profilbilder.
Aber ich habe die nie eingestellt.
Also ich weiß nicht, wo das herkommt. Das ist völlig mysteriös. Aber schau mal, guck doch mal rein, was die gucken. Ich weiß nicht, es klingt so ein bisschen, es ist immer so ein bisschen wie, ja, ich teile ja meinen Account mit meiner Freundin und so und dann denkst du, deine Freundin heißt Will und so. Als würde man, als hätte man imaginäre Freunde, die deinen Account mit einem nutzen, die aber genauso heißen wie man selbst. Das ist ein bisschen merkwürdig. Dein narzisstischer Freund hat immer genere Freunde, die so heißen wie er selbst. Ich habe übrigens auch ein Riesenproblem mit meiner Autorkorrektur, weil mein Handy macht aus Florentin immer automatisch Florentin Will. Und das ist teilweise ein Riesenproblem. Ja, vor allem bei Geburtstagsgrüssen zu nahen, bei nahen Freunden. Liebe Grüße, Florentin Will. Es ist super, es ist super strange. Hi Mama. Ja. Hi Mama, ich will immer fragen, wie es dir so geht. Hat das geklappt irgendwie mit, weiß ich nicht, dem Handwerker? Liebe Grüße, Flo und den Will. Oder auch wenn Leute so schreiben, so, hey, wann kommt die nächste Podcast-Uvo-Folge raus? Schreibt das nie. Und dann so, ja, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung, liebe Grüße, Flo und den Will. Es Florentin will. Es liegt so voll unpersönlich und von oben herab.
Und man kann es auch nicht zurücknehmen, wenn es mal raus ist, weil das ist das Letzte, was man schreibt, und man drückt nach Florentin auf Absenden und die Autokorrektur ist ein riesen Arschloch und es gibt das Wort noch rein, bevor man absennt, man kann nichts dagegen tun, nichts. Das ist eigentlich meine Idee, um eine Beziehung zu charakterisieren zwischen einem Protagonisten und seinen Eltern, ist, dass er Protagonist Geburtstag hat und dann macht er eine Karte auf von seinen Eltern und beide haben mit Vor- und Nachnamen unterschrieben.
Das ist eigentlich ein sehr schnell, guter Moment, um die Beziehung zwischen den Eltern klar zu machen.
Er hat maximal distanziert und so weggeschrieben.
Weil Vor- und Nachnamen ist sofort unpersönlich.
Ich meine, sobald die Mittelnamen reinkommen, wird es strange.
So, dann Florentin Pascal David will, dann ist es merkwürdig. Wie, Moment, Pascal David oder David Pascal? Du änderst die Einfachung aber auch selber manchmal einfach ausspart. FDP, Florentin David Pascal, stimmt. Warum? Das ist ganz merkwürdig, dass du plötzlich dich so sehr von dir selbst distanziert, dass du dann vergessen hast. Das ist meine Charakterisierung für einen Charakter, der weiß nicht mal, wie er heißt. Ne, es ist so, ich weiß, dass ich mein halbes Leben falsch gemacht habe. Das hat irgendwann mal jemand gesagt, so ein Standesbeamter meinte übrigens, sie sagen ihren Namen falsch, weil ich habe die Geburtsökunde mal gecheckt. Es ist Will und es ist Davids, eher so Florenton. Es ist Florenton, Pascal, David, Will. Okay, und seitdem weiß ich nur, oh, ich muss es anders sagen, als ich denke und ich komme da nicht mehr raus. Und es ist so ein, ich weiß, ich habe es immer falsch gemacht. Harbel das Kall. Ja, kann auch sein. Weiß ich nicht. Genau. Es ist ganz merkwürdig, aber benutze ich eher selten tatsächlich. Meinen gesamten Namen ist eher ungewöhnlich, dass das alles man nur... Rufnamen sagt man ja auch. Rufnamen und Mittelnamen. Schwierig. Ich weiß auch nicht, wenn man gibt es verschiedene. Die meisten Dinge macht man intensiv eigentlich auch richtig. Ja, ja, das stimmt, das ist ein gutes Learning auch. Es ist so, ja. Man kann sich auch mal entspannen, die meisten Dinge macht man intensiv richtig. Wie zum Beispiel, was hast du das letzte Mal wirklich richtig gemacht, wo du gesagt hast, das habe ich jetzt wirklich richtig gemacht? Also da hat wirklich alles geklappt. Da lief alles gut. Alles glatt, das ist wirklich selten der Fall. Ach komm, Stefan, du bist ja auch immer so, du machst einfach immer so einen Tag, wo alles gut läuft. Ja, das sind Tage, die einem aber nicht auffallen. Das ist genau wie wenn du an einer Supermarktkasse bist.
Dir fällt ja nie auf,
dass du an einer guten Kasse bist.
Aber ich wollte gerade sagen, weil bei mir... Du riechst dich ja immer nur bewusst auf,
dass du an einer schlechten Kasse bist.
Ja, ich hatte nämlich den perfekten,
weil ich habe die Frage nur gestellt, um zu sagen,
wo ich selber alles richtig war habe.
Ja, ist schon klar.
An der Supermarktkasse tatsächlich hat es perfekt funktioniert.
Ich hatte die Waren in der perfekten Richtung,
ich habe perfektes Timing reingetan, ich habe zum perfekten Zeitpunkt das Geld überreicht, wo die Kassiererin das Geld genommen hat, zur perfekten Zeit alles reingeräumt, Geld genommen, perfekt verabschiedet, alles, jedes Wort richtig gesagt, es war perfekt. Das hätte man so abspeichern müssen, eigentlich Copy und jedes Mal, wenn man es neu macht, nochmal neu reinpasten, einfach, dass man den Teil seines Lebens einfach hat und dann passt es auch wieder.
So, und da war alles richtig.
Was mich tatsächlich ärgert, ist, dass viele, ich weiß nicht, viele Kassierer und Kassiererinnen haben sich das angewöhnt, wenn sie nach dem Geld fragen, schauen sie woanders hin. Sie sagen, er macht 7,60 Euro und schauen nach links und schauen einfach in den Horizont. Ich weiß nicht, wohin. Oder halt auf das Kassenband. Ja, aber oft schauen die wirklich ganz weit weg, einfach weil sie wahrscheinlich, wie gesagt wird, den Leuten ist es unangenehm, wenn man sie anstarrt, während sie das Geld raussuchen. Ist wahrscheinlich dann so passiv-aggressiv. Aber deswegen schauen sie weg und ich bin in der Regel viel zu schnell und hab das Geld sofort da und die Person schaut wett und ich dann so ein Bip, Bip, Bip, Bip, Bip. Was kommt denn da geflogen? Süße Hallo. Es ist sehr unangenehm. Wie Drummer, die immer nach unten links gucken. Wo ja auch nichts ist, aber Schlagzeuger gucken immer nach unten links. Das ist ein gutes Buch einfach. Nur mal Moby Dick, wenn man durchgeht. Ja, ich denke, man kann so ein iPad hinlegen, wie eine Folge Fargo schauen. Aber es ist immer dieser Blick nach unten links, man weiß nicht genau, was da ist. Ja, aber das ist genau, es sind so automatisierte Blicke. Ich glaube, man kann so ein iPad hinlegen, wie eine Folge Fargo schauen. Es ist immer dieser Blick nach unten links, man weiß nicht genau, was da ist. Aber es sind so automatisierte Blicke. Ich glaube, die meisten, einer hat angefangen, eine Kassiererin, und die andere hat dann selber was gekauft im Supermarkt, war selber Kassiererin, hat mir das aufgefallen, oh, der Kassierer macht so. Es gibt diesen Linksblick aber oft, es gibt auch beim Tanzen oft, also ich schaue mir oft Leute an, coole Leute, die tanzen, und ich denke, wow, wie kann man so cool tanzen? Das ist aber auch neu. Naja, und was die oft machen, ist dieser Blick nach links. So, die tanzen und dann so dieser coole, ich glaube, links ist die coole Seite, oder? Die meisten Leute sagen von sich, dass links die Schokoladenseite ist. Ich glaube, 80 Prozent. Da muss man nach rechts schauen, damit man die linke Seite zur Geltung kommt, ne? Ja. Aber ich glaube, links ist so die coole Seite auch. Stell dir jemanden in einem Auto vor. Ich glaube, es kommt vom Auto. Stell dir jemanden in einem Auto vor. Autofahrer an der Ampel, Arm natürlich raus und dann der coole Blick nach links. Das ist der klassische Blick. Ich glaube, das kommt noch aus dem Mittelalter, wenn ein anderer Ritter an dir vorbeireitet. Du reitest ja auf der rechten Seite, und dann reitest und dann guckst du nach links.
Aber ist man in England auch schon links geritten? Das ist jetzt die Frage. Nee, wirklich. Das ist eine ernsthafte Frage. Ist man in England, wann hat sich Linksverkehr etabliert? War das schon im Mittelalter der Fall? Weil ich glaube, Rechtsfahren, das Rechtsfahrgebot ist älter als Strassen. Also seitdem es Wege gibt und Menschen muss es ja eine Richtung geben, in die man eher geht auf der einen Seite. Oder ist man einfach Anarchie, man ist überall lang gelaufen, wo man gerade der Fuß hintreibt. Solange man nicht stirbt, kann man machen, was man will. Es ist eine gute Frage, aber ich habe tatsächlich gelesen, dass weil wir Rechtsverkehr haben, sterben jedes Jahr Fahrradfahrer. Weil der Fahrradfahrer ist in der Regel rechts von dir und du sitzt links, siehst den nicht, fährst den umtot. Und in England sterben weniger Radfahrer. Da fahren die Radfahrer nicht auch links, neben denen, und die sitzen aber rechts und die Radfahrer fahren aber auch links. Das ist ja genauso übersetzt auf die andere Seite. Ja, ja, jetzt siehst du, das ist der Blick, das den kenne ich. Das ist der beschämte Blick nach links. Das ist der beschämte, nee, nach rechts, die unkohle Seite. Ja, stimmt. Ja, du hast, stimmt, verdammt. Das ist ja auch übersetzt. Du hast recht, aber ist es nicht, dass eine Abbiegung anders ist? Dass sie auch nach oben abbiegen können oder irgendwie sowas oder nach unten? Nein, man kann da viel machen in England. Ach, ich weiss es nicht. Du hast ja die gleichen Probleme auch, weil bei uns ist das Linksabbiegen immer ein großes Problem, da ist das Rechtsabbiegen ein großes Problem. Das ist ja einfach egal, das ist einfach ein Spiegel vorgesetzt. Aber der Körper ist doch nicht ganz gleich. Nee, allein weil unser Herz ja auf der linken Seite ist. Ja, aber der Körper hat doch auch einen Drall, so ein bisschen, oder? So einen leichten Drall. Nee, wir haben einen Linksdrall. Genau, einen Linksdrall. Deswegen sind Supermärkte ja auch links herum gebaut. Jeder Supermarkt, du musst ja in jedem Supermarkt eine Linkskurve gehen. Ah, ja. Jetzt kommen wir irgendwo hin. Ich weiß noch nicht wohin, aber wir kommen irgendwo hin. Aber wäre es dann nicht besser, den Supermarkt rechts rumzubauen, damit man eher in so ein Regal reinläuft? Der Mensch will, ja, gut, aber der Supermarkt will ja auch ein Wohlfühlgefühl auslösen. Du gehst jetzt von einem sehr kapitalistischen Supermarkt aus, aber da gehst du nicht nochmal rein, weil das ist nicht so offensichtlich. Der Linkstrall gibt dir das Gefühl, zu Hause zu sein. Linkstrall und Teppich. Das sind die beiden Geheimnisse für die menschliche Psyche, Linkstrall und Teppich. Ja, man verlangsamt nämlich, deswegen sind bei der Galeria Kaufhof oder bei Karstadt da, wo die Waren sind, dann immer Teppiche. Ist aber auch, glaube ich, mittlerweile nicht mehr so. Aber früher war das zumindest so, weil da verlangsamst du dann den Schritt und dann bist du gemächlicher. Man geht auf Teppichen langsamer als auf hartem Boden. Wow, du bist so schlau. Ich hatte ja einen Teppichboden in meinem Kinderzimmer und hatte dann irgendwann so einen Stuhl, mit dem man rollen konnte. Und dann gab es immer so die Position am Schreibtisch. Ich hatte zwei Schreibtische. Einen Schreibtisch zum Hausaufgaben machen und so. Einen Pfandschreibtisch. Und einen Pfandschreibtisch der Krawallschreibtisch mit meinem PC drauf, wo ich World of Warcraft gezockt habe. Und dann bin ich mit meinem Rollstuhl oft zwischen dem einen und dem anderen Schreibtisch hin und her. Und irgendwann waren in dem Teppich wirklich so Spurrillen drin, wo ich nur noch in die grobe Richtung mich drücken musste und die Rillen für mich übernommen haben. Wie so ein Schienensystem. Es war genial. Es war wirklich einfach, aber wo man sich auch jemand, der Nachkäufer, kauft diesen Teppich und denkt sich einfach so, was ist da passiert, was ist da geschehen? Einfach so über Jahre hinweg, einfach jeden Tag mehrmals hin und her. Die Regionalbahn ist immer durch mein Zimmer gefahren. Ja, und man kann auch nicht abweichen. Wenn man so ein Schienensystem mal hat und ich versuche, woanders hin zu rollen, es geht nicht. Du kommst immer wieder in das Schienensystem rein. Ich finde Schienen auch fantastisch.
Ich kann mir auch immer nicht vorstellen, wie das genau funktioniert.
Wenn ich im Zug sitze, denke ich mir jedes Mal,
das kann doch nicht überall gleich breit sein, der Abstand.
Ja.
Das geht doch gar nicht.
Selbst wenn du ganz genau arbeitest, geht das doch nicht.
Und sind die Bahnen so ausgelegt, haben die so einen Spielraum, weißt du, geben die mal nach, nach links und rechts ein Millimeterchen.
Mehr muss es ja gar nicht sein, meinetwegen.
Es ist natürlich, ich weiss es nur tatsächlich aus dem Ersten Weltkrieg, dass es ein Problem war, dass als die Deutschen am Anfang ein bisschen nach Frankreich reingestossen sind, bevor sie aufgehalten wurden, die konnten nicht die französischen Gleise benutzen, weil die etwas schmaler waren als die deutschen Züge und die konnten da nicht drauf fahren. Eigentlich super smart, wenn man mal drüber nachdenkt, ich weiß nicht, ob es Absicht ist oder nicht, aber die mussten das erst umbauen oder eigene Züge oder Züge klauen oder Züge von den Franzosen kaufen oder so, um dann darauf fahren zu können. Riesenproblem. Das ist ja geil. Das ist genial. Fantastisch. Ist fantastisch. Diese kleinen Dinge, die freuen mich dann immer so. Ganz aufregend, guckst du nach links gerade. Wenn ich einen anderen Podcast hätte, würde ich es da erzählen. Ja, stimmt. Die verbreitet sich so ein bisschen. Ja, das sollte man weiter erzählen, finde ich. Das ist eine ganz tolle, herzerwärmende Geschichte. Ich übertre lese auch gerade so ein Buch zum Ausbruch des Ersten Weltkriegs und einem fällt auch einfach mal auf. Wie ist das denn die Liebensweltkriege eigentlich? Ja, ja. Es fällt einem auch einfach auf, wie viele Länder einem auch scheißegal sind, wie viele Länder auch so geschichtlich völlig irrelevant sind, da dieses ganze Balkanzeug, was da davor passiert ist, irgendwie Bulgarien, Serbien, Bosnien, alles, alles coole Länder, aber wenn man so die klassische deutsche Schulaufbahn durchgemacht hat, Länder, von denen man nie was mitkriegt und auch einfach egal, die haben ihr ganzes eigenes Zeug und super wichtig auch für die Weltgeschichte, aber hat man einfach nie mitbekommen. Und man denkt sich dann so, ja, wo ist das genau, wo ist, weiß kein Mensch auch. Ja, vor allem, das hat mich dann schockiert, weil ich in Kroatien war, für meine materielle Karfahrt. Und es hat einfach immer noch ein bisschen wie ein Nachkriegsort gewirkt, weil der ist ja nicht so lange, wahnsinnig lange her, der Krieg. Und man merkt das an so Dingen wie, ja, wie so Brot und so. Es sind Löcher drin. Hier wurde gekämpft noch. Die sind durchschossen. Nein, aber das ist alles wirkt noch so wie das noch so wir räumen gerade noch ein bisschen auf. So, wir sind, in ein paar Jahren sind wir dann da. Kommt in dem Jahr nochmal wieder. Wir kommen, wir kommen. Ja, aber gibt uns noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Aber wir waren auch kein guter Auge, weil es auch sehr billig sein musste und so. Aber da ist es mir zum ersten Mal klar geworden.
Es brauchte mein Mathe-LK, um die Geschichte, um die Welt zu entdecken, um die Geschichte Kroatiens zu verstehen. Und was genau ist dir da klar geworden? Naja, dass der Krieg da noch nicht so lange her war und das gar nicht in meinem Bewusstsein war, dass vor ein paar Jahren da noch gekämpft wurde. Letztens habe ich mir auch überlegt, wie unfassbar wenig Ahnung man von Afrika hat. Null! Also ich meine zum Beispiel sowas wie, was Kultur angeht und Religion. Also jetzt mal so Indien, da weiss man, ah, Vishnu, Ganesha, diese weirden Tentakelleute und so. Sag mir mal einen afrikanischen Gott. Ja, jetzt kann ich dir mit Ägypten kommen, doch, aber na ja gut, aber jetzt, das ist ja nicht, ja, okay. Das ist ja wirklich schon antik, das ist ja wirklich schon super alt. Naja, na gut, weiß ich nicht, nee. Aber da haben wir noch kein Plan. Aber ich glaube auch, weil es so wahnsinnig divers ist, oder? Weil auch jedes Land ... Das ist ein großes Land, ja. ... unfassbar anders ist. Ja, ist es wirklich so? Ja, es gibt dieses tolle Video von Fahri in Urlaub, wie er alle Länder Afrikas, wie er zu jedem Land Afrikas eine Meinung hat. Weil er reist einfach wahnsinnig gern und deswegen heißt er auch Fahrer in Urlaub. Und er reist wahnsinnig gern und vor allem durch Afrika und fotografiert, hat auch ganz tolle Bilderbände rausgebracht, Fotobücher. Und dann, ich weiß gar nicht, von 1Live oder sowas, dann halten sie ihm eine Karte hin. Und dann zeigen Sie ihm einfach, zeigen sie sich auf dem Land und er sagt, zeigen sie sich auf dem Land in Afrika und er weiss genau, wie das Land heisst, was schon mal echt eine Leistung ist, weil es sind wahnsinnig viele Länder in Afrika und hat immer zu jedem Land eine Geschichte, was unglaublich ist und das ist so, da merkt man erstmal, wie wenig man über Afrika weiss und das ist total cool, er sagt dann, ja, Äthiopien, das waren die unterschzt, eigentlich das schönste Land, Landschaft, das spricht und so, hier und da, ja, da ist es noch so ein bisschen unsicher, dann da und da wurde immer eine Waffe ins Gesicht gehalten und so was. Also auch krasse Geschichten dann zu erzählen, weil er so auf eigene Faust da rumreist und so. Aber es ist schon spannend. Ich glaube, man weiss zu wenig darüber. Krass. Wäre das mal was für uns?
Auch wenn ich mal so ... Das Podcast auf wo goes Africa?
Ja, ja.
Auch mal so, sag mal so ein typisch afrikanisches Essensgericht.
Antilope.
Antilopenfleisch.
Puschiertes Antilopenfleisch mit Giraffenhals.
Giraffen.
Werden Giraffen gegessen eigentlich?
Ist das eine Delikatesse der Hals? Nein. Nee, gar nicht? Gar nicht. Nee, weil du mit diesen süßen Hörnchen auch. Nee, Giraffen, glaube ich, den tut man nicht. Nee, die sind zu gross, die kann man gar nicht aufessen. Die haben einfach ein geiles Gadget. Tiere mit einem geilen Gadget. Kühe haben kein Gadget. Nee. Milch, aber das wird ihnen zu verhängt. Ja, die sind so, die sind gefleckt, das ist schon cool. Ja, die schmecken gut und geben Milch, also die haben die worst Gadgets possible. Schwein, auch nur viel Fleisch, super, macht einfach Sinn zu essen und zu messen, aber Giraffen haben ein super geiles Gadget, deswegen werden die nicht gegessen. Zebras haben auch ein geiles Gadget und werden deswegen nicht wie Pferde missbraucht. Ich denke auch, wenn ich als Tier wiedergeboren wäre, würde ich mir denken, hoffentlich bin ich nicht lecker. Stell dir vor, du bist so ein kleines Tier und du hast ja keine Ahnung von Tieren. Das heißt, du kannst ja erstmal nicht erkennen, welche Art von Tier du bist, weil du bist ja so ein kleiner Wurm. Du kannst ja so einen Babyfrosch kannst du ja nicht von einer Babygiraffe unterscheiden, nehme ich mal an. Gut, schlechtes Beispiel. Aber Babywurm von einem Baby irgendwas anderem. Würmchen. Würmchen, ja. Oder verschiedene Käfer kannst du dich unterscheiden und denkst dir erstmal, was bin ich überhaupt? Welche Art von Tier bin ich? Kenne ich mich überhaupt oder bin ich ein Tier, das ich noch nie gehört habe? Wie denke ich überhaupt ohne Sprache? Das ist mal spannend. So, kann ich überhaupt denken? Kann ich das, was ich überhaupt denke, gerade verstehen? Oh, das ist, finde ich, auch schwierig. Ich finde es total gruselig, wenn man über Sprache nachdenkt. Damit möchte ich mich in den nächsten Monaten und Jahren auch mehr auseinandersetzen. Also ich messe weiter meinen Kühlschrank und du beschäftigst dich intensiv mit Sprache. Ja, zum einen, weil es irgendwie der Beruf ist, den man sich ausgesucht hat. Auf der anderen Seite, wie funktioniert Sprache und funktioniert Denken nur über Sprache. Und ich verstehe Sprachen manchmal wie so ein Betriebssystem ja auch. Es gibt uns so ein bisschen die Richtung vor. Erstmal ist ja alles möglich, das Gehirn ist ja viel zu komplex als die 26 Buchstaben, die wir haben, in den Grammatikformen, die wir haben, in den vier Fällen, die wir formen. Es ist eigentlich alles, es ist lächerlich komplex für die Mittel, die wir haben, um die Gedanken auszudrücken. Deswegen glaube ich, dass Dinge, die wir sagen, wir sind nie ehrlich, weil wir nie ausdrücken können, was wir gerade, was wir fühlen, weil wir zu wenig Wörter haben, um das auszudrücken. Ich glaube, da sind manche Sprachen besser drin als andere Sprachen und ich glaube, deswegen sind manche Sprachen noch ehrlicher als andere Sprachen. Und ich glaube, dass Sprachen, deswegen ist es auch wichtig zu sprechen die ganze Zeit, um selber sich zu überprüfen, meint man das eigentlich gerade, was man spricht? Verstehst du? Ja. Ich habe, also, wenn du, du denkst, glaube ich auch abstrakter, als dass du sprichst. Ich glaube, in meinem Kopf habe ich oft etwas, was ich wahnsinnig toll finde und cool und komplex und da staune ich drüber. Und dann sage ich es und es klingt ultra langweilig. Ja. Das habe ich total häufig. Ich auch so. Ich denke mir, oh, was für ein geiler Gedanke und dann sage ich es und dann denke ich mir, das klingt super dumm. Aber auch nicht, und dann bin ich aber nicht nur, ich finde den Gedanken immer noch interessant, ich habe nur die richtigen Wörter gefunden, um diesen Gedanken auszudrücken. Und ich glaube, das zeigt dann manchmal so ein bisschen, oder auch wenn du dann wirklich, ich müsste eigentlich mal mit dem Therapeuten sprechen, weil ich glaube, je mehr du sagst über dich, desto mehr lernst du, was meinst du davon eigentlich gerade wirklich, weil beim Aussprechen merkst du erst, na, das war in meinem Kopf anders und eigentlich bin ich anders als das, was ich gerade sage. Ich finde das spannend. Ich finde, Sprache ist noch nicht, wir sind noch nicht am Ende. Du, ich bin sehr gespannt, auf welche Wege dich das führt. Halt uns da bitte auf dem Laufenden, wo du dich da hinbewegst auf deiner Quest gegen die Sprache. Ich glaube, was mir helfen könnte, ist Psychoanalyse. Sprache ist auch ein großes Thema. Ich kann nochmal den LaCast empfehlen, Florianis Podcast, über Psychoanalyse und Jacques Lacan. Ganz spannend. Aber ja, ich glaube, da muss ich noch ein bisschen was dazulernen. Ich bin jetzt wieder auf dem, ich weiss, es ist immer so ein bisschen eine Auf- und Abwärtsbewegung, ich will wieder Französisch lernen. Ich habe wieder Motivation gepackt, ich habe es ein bisschen schleifen lassen, bin jetzt wieder dabei und habe jetzt auch einige und es ist ja krass, weil es gibt ja mittlerweile super viele Angebote auch zum Thema Podcast oder so, um Französisch zu lernen und es gibt auch viele Podcasts, wo einfach leicht französisch geredet wird, also wo man sich einfach auch so Interviewpodcast, es ist super spannend, wo du den Experten einlädst, weil das Problem ist ja oft, solche Sprache in Sprachlernbüchern ist unglaublich uninteressant. Wo ist das zu? Donner ist da der Bibliothek. Ubi ist Cornelia, Ad Flumen ist, ist mir scheißegal. Das heißt, es ist so ein Disconnect zwischen, ich will die Sprache lernen, aber das Thema interessiert mich nicht. Und deswegen gibt es viele Podcasts, die gesagt haben, wir versuchen interessante Themen, aber so dass man sie leicht versteht. Das heißt, ich will immer so vor. Dem crazy geile Experten, Anna Frebel zu Gast. Genau, da kommt dann Anna Frebel. Aber Redenheit wird vollidiot. Und sagt, Frau Frebel, reden Sie bitte sehr langsam und sehr deutlich. Und am besten in einer einfacheren Sprache. Vermeiden Sie die Vergangenheit und die Zukunft und grosse Worte. Sterne sind geboren. Ich finde Sterne im Himmel. Alles ist wahnsinnigig angestrengt auch. Aber versuchen Sie es trotzdem interessant und spritzig zu halten.
Ich finde, grosse Sterne im weiten Himmelszelte. Ja? Oh, das ist ein schwieriger Fall, im Zelte. Das müssen wir noch mal neu machen, Frau Frebel. Ich finde grosse Sterne im Weltall mit meinem grossen Teleskop in Chile.
Was ist ein Teleskop?
Mit einem Teleskop kann ... Ist passiver laut?
Nein.
Oh. Finde ich besser Sterne, weil es mein Bild, was ich sehe, vergrössert. Was bedeutet vergrössern? Größer machen. Du Depp. Größer machen, du dummes Arschloch. Aber wir haben tatsächlich, wir kriegen ab und zu auch Nachrichten so, hey, ich bin irgendwie Däne, ich bin nach Deutschland gezogen und ich lerne durch euren Podcast Deutsch. Ja, keine gute Idee. was ich krass finde, weil ich könnte mir im Leben nicht ein normales Gespräch auf Französisch anhören, never ever. Ein guter Freund von mir ist, kommt aus Chicago, wohnt schon länger in Deutschland, spricht unglaublich gutes Deutsch, hat auch viele unserer Drehbücher übersetzt für Netflix und der hört unseren Podcast manchmal und korrigiert uns. Und er sagt, und ich spreche, dachte ich immer sehr normal mit ihm.
Aber wie es scheint, er meinte, ich spreche ganz anders mit dir im Podcast als mit ihm, weil die Sprachgeschwindigkeit ist eine andere, ich benutze mehr Nebensätze und so weiter.
Du bist herablassender zu mir und beleidigender.
Genau, und ich glaube, dass ich anders, also anscheinend spreche ich wirklich anders mit ihm und ich auch, ist wirklich dann total unterbewusst gewesen, weil ich immer dachte, ich habe ihn immer als ebenbürtigen Sprachkumpel wahrgenommen, aber nee, es war dann doch augenscheinlich ein bisschen was anderes. Es ist eigentlich immer eine spannende Idee, Leute zu erschliessen durch verschiedene Leute, die sie kennen. Also angenommen, du willst ein Interview mit Farin Urlaub machen, nahel naheliegende Idee, lad Fahri in Urlaub ein. Nee, lad Leute ein, die er kennt. Lad mal seine Mutter und seinen besten Freund ein und lass die miteinander über ihn reden, was für unterschiedliche Vorstellungen die von ihm haben. Ich glaube, jeder Mensch ist zu jedem anders. Genau, aber ihn dadurch zu entschlüsseln, welche verschiedenen Facetten er hat. Ich bin ein soziales Chamameleon. Ja? Ja. Ich bin bei sehr wenigen Menschen der, der ich sein will und zu jedem Menschen ein bisschen anders. Ich kann mich sehr gut auf verschiedene Gruppen einlassen, glaube ich. Es ist aber verschieden anstrengend, also verschiedene Abende mit verschiedenen Leuten sind unterschiedlich anstrengend für mich. Aber hat es auch Grenzen oder wenn jetzt wirklich, hey komm,, komm, lass uns mal so auf eine X-City-Party gehen und du... Hat auf jeden Fall Grenzen. Ja? Da ist die Grenze. Okay. Ja. Na, wobei, das ist schon sehr weit gefasst bei mir. Ich kann mich so einstellen. Aber zum gewissen Grad platzern auch irgendwann die... Ich sag mal, ich bin vor ein paar Jahren auf dem Dortmunder Friesensplatz gewesen und habe das Pokalfinale geschaut. Der FI-Pokalfinale zwischen Dortmund und Frankfurt. Ganz komische Sache, dass ich da gelandet bin, da war ich in der Heimat, habe Freunde getroffen und dann wollten die da abends hin und dann war ich da plötzlich dann da und hatte gar keine Lust, auf das Fussballspiel zu gucken. Ich wollte lieber mit den Leuten reden und wollte dann nicht das Fussballspiel gucken. Und da bin ich aufgefallen. Da konnte ich, bei diesen Fans konnte ich nicht das soziale Chamäleon sein. Es haben sich Leute vor mir, die vor mir auf das Spiel geguckt haben, umgedreht zu mir, um zu gucken, was es für ein Exot ist. Als Fremdkörper wahrgenommen wird. Ich wurde als Fremdkörper. Wie so ein Pickel wurdest du rausgedrückt von den anderen. Ja, genau, also die Körpereigenen Substanzen haben mich als Fremdkörper entlarvt. Und da haben diese Blutkörperchen auf mich gestürzt und mich rausgebracht.
Ja, ja, ja, nee, da hat es dann auch Grenzen. Also du verstehst, was ich meine, man ist menschlich anders.
Ja, klar. Wie anders bist du dann? Was feinertest du dich? Sehr anders. Es ist immer sehr unangenehm, wenn dann solche Kreise aufeinandertreffen, wenn dann irgendwie tatsächlich auch verschiedene Freundeskreise auch so. Es ist ja wirklich schon ein so, auch wenn ich jetzt natürlich mit allen freundschaftlich bin, aber es gibt, wenn jetzt der eine Freundeskreis auf den anderen trifft, ich denke mir, beide entlarven mich gerade, weil ich kann, wenn ich jetzt zu den einen so bin, checken die anderen es und wenn ich zu den anderen bin. Wenn der jetzt diese eine Geschichte anspricht, die ich ihm erzählt habe, und dann rauskommt, das war nie so.
Ja, die können mich jetzt einfach komplett entlarven. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich werde heute Abend noch verhaftet, weil ich fliege auf hier gerade. Herr Bills sind aufgeflogen. Verhaftet. Herr Bills sind verhaftet wegen aufgeflogen. Gut, verhaftet. Haben zu viel Quatsch erzählt. Nee, die dürfen sich auch nicht berühren. Das sind so wie verschiedene Gerichte. Terrarien. Die dürfen sich nicht vermischen. Ja, du hast eine Schlange und du hast einen Frosch, aber die hältst du getrennt, weil du bist ja nicht komplett bescheuert. Du weißt nicht, wer von beiden stirbt, wenn du die zusammenbringst, aber einer wird sterben, relativ sicher. Vielleicht sogar beide. Möglicherweise. Es kann gut sein, dass beide sterben. Möglicherweise verschluckt er sich und ist tot. Der Frosch jetzt. Auch immer so ein bisschen so, wenn ein Freund von einem eine neue Freundin hat und die dann das erste Mal mitbringt und man meint, werkt sofort so, er ist zwischen zwei Menschen gefangen, weil er ist ein Mensch zu freundlich. Er will immer noch der coole Freund sein, aber er will vor ihr auch der coole Freund sein. Und das funktioniert häufig nicht.
Und oft ist es aber so, dass der eigene Freundeskreis dann mitmacht und seine Charade mit aufgreift und man plötzlich so ein Theaterstück hat für die neue Freundin. Und alle checken, oh, wir müssen jetzt hier was anderes machen. Und plötzlich ist es wie so eine Privatvorstellung für die neue Freundin. Und man merkt genau, wir sind alle nicht wir selbst gerade, aber wir wollen ihn gut dastehen lassen und wir wollen das, was er tut, möglichst gut unterstützen und in seinem Theaterstück mitspielen. Ich liebe ja solche Situationen auffliegen zu lassen. Ja? Ja, ich bin aber auch. Dann vielleicht entweder kein guter Freund oder ich mag das zu sehr, aber in solchen Situationen zu sagen, Moment, das hast du noch niemals gesagt. Ich bin niemals dann so, dass ich, weil ich will immer noch am besten dastehen an diesem Abend. Klar, du merkst, die Aufmerksamkeit ist gerade nicht auf mich gerichtet und musst möglichst viel Chaos reinbringen. Ich glaube, ich habe neulich gedacht, ich habe billig mit dem Gedanken gespielt, mal irgendwann zum Therapeuten zu gehen, welches ich schon interessant finde. Und da habe ich darüber nachgedacht, was würde ich dem erzählen? Und ich dachte mir, eigentlich will ich doch der spannendste Patient sein einfach. Und deswegen wird das nicht funktionieren, weil ich natürlich mich viel interessanter machen will, als ich bin und viel komplexer und viel problembehafteter, als es eigentlich ist. Aber machen das nicht alle, wollen nicht alle, das weiß ich nicht. Aber ich will auf jeden Fall, ich habe das Ziel auch, der krasseste Patient zu werden. Ich will der sein, ich will den nicht langweilen mit meinem Leben. Vor allem ist es ja oft veröffentlichten Therapeuten ja auch Fälle und so Bücher, wo sie Sachen beschreiben. Und ich denke mir, jeder Patient, jeder seiner Patienten von diesem Psychoanalytiker oder Therapeuten kauft dieses Buch, um zu wissen, stehe ich da drin oder nicht. Weil ich will schon der interessante Fall sein, wo dieses Symptom total gut, ja, bin ich natürlich. Und einfach, ich will der interessanteste sein. Ja, ich will der über den, der das erste Buch sein. Genau, ja. Und auch wenn so der Therapeut fragt, wäre es okay, wenn ich meine Doktorarbeit über sie schreiben würde? Ja! Klar! Klar! So klagen sie noch nie. Was ist das für eine Stimme? Was ist das für eine Stimme? Was machen sie jetzt? Jutta! Aber es gibt da total spannende Dynamiken. Aber hast du da gute Bücher zu empfehlen? Ja. Kannst du mir gleich mal empfehlen? Kann ich dir empfehlen. Wenn die Aufnahme vorbei ist? Kann ich dir empfehlen. Nicht für die Hörer hier, das soll zwischen uns sein. Kann ich dir empfehlen. Aber es gibt da total spannende Dynamiken, auch zum Beispiel bei Narzissten. Wenn ein Narzisst in Therapie geht und die Therapie Erfolg hat und sich Symptome lindern, sagen wir mal, dann kommt beim Narzissten der Punkt, der sagt, oh shit, der Therapeut hat ja was drauf, das darf ja nicht sein, weil ich bin ja der Beste und dadurch wird es wieder schlimmer. Das heißt, in dem Moment, in dem die Therapie Erfolg hat, macht der Narzissmus den Erfolg wieder kaputt. Was den Therapeuten aber wiederum ja zeigt, dass er auf dem richtigen Weg ist. Genau, aber es trotzdem kaputt macht, weil sozusagen selbst der Erfolg für den Narzissen eigentlich nicht schlecht ist, weil es ihm zeigt, der Therapeut ist besser als ich. Der hat mich unter Kontrolle, der kann mich verändern. Der kratzt an meinem Genie. Genau. Und das heißt, der Statue, den ich mir gebaut habe selber. Ja, das ist total faszinierend. Das ist spannend. Du, mach das, ich bin gespannt und dann kannst du ja einen Podcast draus machen. Mein Weg. Mein Weg zu mir. Aber es ist ja auch ein klassischer Vorwurf, dass man vielleicht Kreativität verliert. Also es gab viele Leute, gerade so in der Zeit von Freud oder so gab es viele Genies, halt so in diesem klassischen Wiener Kreis und sowas, die gesagt haben, sie machen es nicht, weil sie dann Angst haben, keine Genies mehr zu sein, wenn ihre ganzen inneren Dämonen besiegt sind und so und dadurch nicht mehr das sozusagen ihre ganzen dunklen Antriebe haben, die sie in ihrer Kreativität ausleben können. Ja, wobei ich auch das Gegenteil gehört habe, auch gerade wenn man Comedy macht, es soll sehr gut sein, über sich selber distanziert zu sprechen und sich ein bisschen näher zu kommen, um darüber auch auslachen zu können. Weiß ich nicht. Weiß ich auch nicht. Du, ich weiß es auch nicht. Ich bin immer sehr gespannt, was da aus wird. du verändere dich nicht zu sehr. Nee, nee, nee. Und wenn, dann weiß ich ja, dass du mich wieder erden wirst, dass ich die wieder zurückhole. Ja, nicht privat, aber vor Leuten hier in diesem Projekt. Ja, wenn das in der Therapie rauskommt, einfach so alles, das ist glaube ich auch eine Simpsons-Folge oder so, wo irgendwie alles kommt auf Homer zusammen. Alle merken, dass Homer das Problem ist und er einfach nur weg sein müsste und dann ging es allen anderen gut. So ist es vielleicht bei dir auch, dass es einfach so, alle roten Fäden laufen bei mir zusammen. Genau, ich frage mich auch, wie unsere Beziehung ist, weil wir exklusiv vor Leuten miteinander sprechen. Nein, das stimmt nicht. Wir haben schon manchmal so die Nächte durchgemacht, so an so einem kleinen Lagerfeuerchen. Aber man muss schon sagen, dass wir einen Grossteil unserer, also ich glaube, du hast mit kaum jemandem so viel Zeit vor Leuten gesprochen. Ich meine, jede Woche eine Stunde vor Leuten zu sprechen, muss ja auch was mit uns machen. Das kann ja nicht einfach so darauf an uns vorbeiziehen. Das freut mich aber auch mal, was das wirklich, was da so ein Psychoanalytiker zu sagen würde. Du, wir können gerne mal in die Paartherapie gehen und mal wirklich alles auf den Tisch legen, was uns so beschäftigt. Weil man redet ja von einem Haufen Leuten anders. Aber ich weiß ja gar nicht, ob man das selber überhaupt so gut sagen kann oder ob das wie gesagt zum Thema Farin-Urlaub-Interview nicht die anderen Leute eher beurteilen können, so hey, du bist zu mir so, du bist zu mir so. Ja, ich würde jetzt gerne deine Mutter und deinen besten Freund hier interviewen, aber geht leider nicht. Das wäre so lustig, wenn wir das machen. Wir machen mal eine Folge. Deine Mutter, meine Mutter und beste Freunde. Die vier Leute an einem Tisch. Gut, das wäre natürlich unser narzisstischer Traum, vier Leute in eine Stunde über uns reden. Das wäre aber eigentlich geil für Folge 1000 oder sowas. Ja. Gar nicht so schlecht einfach. Dann kommt alles raus. Es kommt ja Folge 200 bald, lasst uns einfach unsere Mütter miteinander reden. Das ist gar nicht so schlecht. Und dann will ich aber viel Schnittrechte haben. Und dann sind die lustiger als wir und dann können wir einpacken. Ja. Mütter-Podcast finde ich ganz gut. Wir machen den eigenen Podcast weiter. Die Mütter finde ich mega. Wir würden, ich glaube, danach würde uns niemand mehr hören, weil dann ist, dann ist, dann ist, dann ist. Dann ist alles gebrochen. Ja, dann ist die Religion zerstört, der Vorhang. Der Vorhang wurde gelüftet, es wurde hinter die Kulissen geschaut. Ja, na ja, stimmt schon. Na gut, ja, das war's. Wir wünschen euch eine fantastische Woche. Viel Spaß, weil ihr habt. Viel Spaß bei eurer Woche. Ja, viel Spaß bei eurer Woche.
Gebt mal gut essen.
Ja, gebt mal gut essen. Gebt mal gut essen, guckt mal einen schönen Film.
Gebt mal ins Kino, genau, geht mal am Nachmittag ins Kino.
Welchen Film? Läuft gerade, Joker läuft gerade.
Ja, schaut euch Parasite an.
Parasite, da war ich richtig Spaß von koreanischen Filmen.
Da freue ich mich sehr drauf. Haut rein, macht's gut.
Vielen Dank an Trommel-Torben
und Polter-Holger für uns dieses fantastische Intro. Vielen, vielen Dank. Haut rein, macht's gut. Vielen Dank an Trommeltorben und Polter Holger für unser fantastisches Intro.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Haut rein, macht's gut.
Macht's gut, ciao. Thank you.